similar let's jump to this this story
here this one they want this is the
story we're originally going to lead
with
this is from conventionofstates.com
large majority of independents
republicans believe trump's political
enemies are behind the fbi raid and are
now more likely to vote in 2022 midterms
this is uh from trafalgar group in the
convention of states they say 83 of
republicans 72 percent of independents
now more likely to vote i mean that's
really good news if you want republicans
to win that's the best get out the vote
effort the government's ever had right
but but right and so there's a few
points to be made the first thing i want
to say is there's no guarantee
republicans winning does anything for
anybody granted seeing more like america
first style politicians who are just
like more like ron paul like just know
we're gonna we're send government
authority and things like that i can
accept as
it's better in my opinion that many of
these candidates win then the democrats
retain control and steam steamroll
through things but i have to wonder
was the fb
if there's no political motivation in
what the fbi is doing
then
they don't care that this is riling up
independent voters republican voters
unless
there is political motivation which i
think most people believe there is
so my assumption now is october surprise
that in about two and a half months
these rays and subpoenas the reason
they're doing it now is so they can have
the filings done they can have the
judge's signatures and then come the end
of october it's bam criminal indictment
criminal indictment accusation
accusation the entirety of the of the
corporate press will be dominated with
republican arrested republican arrested
so they don't lose the midterms how else
do they expect
with massive inflation
with horrible gas prices i know they've
come down quite a bit bravo but they're
still really high
the misery index is so high and the
historical trends democrats should get
wiped out in the midterms
unless they can pull some insane october
surprise and make a bunch of arrests
maybe maybe not but that's kind of what
it feels like to me here huh i feel like
i'd go one step further to say
the ultimate goal to what you're talking
about before was
they want to try and prevent trump from
running again and if they
destroy the credibility of anyone who is
kind of positioned as an ally to him as
someone who has supported him
not just like he's a bad guy we don't
like it but he's literally on trial he's
in jail they're hoping to win enough
support
to make it seem like
it's an absolute
non-starter we cannot elect donald trump
uh i don't think they have a better
candidate i don't think joe biden will
be able to run again so really what
they're trying to do is knock the
republican republicans most likely most
likely chess piece off the table to try
and get ahead of whatever's going to
happen next because they are in a weak
position themselves larry elder said it
has to be kamala harris
because why
because uh democrats are dependent upon
the black vote and that if they abandon
kamala harris for someone else it's
going to be deeply hurtful to the black
community she's not competent but that's
that's very deeply unpopular i don't i
don't know if i necessarily agree but
far be it for me to claim to know better
than than larry
cortez
i mean it's almost like is she actually
going to run for president that'd be
cool i hope she's got to be someone to
listen
to
we talked about before a trump aoc
debate
yes that's great great so i i got i got
i got a couple angry emails from people
they're like how dare you say you would
like to see aoc run for president i'm
like yeah i think it'd be hilarious i
mean fantastic that's way better than
what the democratic governor's
association is doing to their voters
right they're pouring money into races
to get the quote-unquote most extreme
candidate elected so they can
theoretically beat them in the middle
but but think about that the democrats
have been funding we know this the the
maga candidates the trump supporting
candidates or they've been funding their
messages really yeah yes oh my god so uh
weird it was uh
the idea is
that trump candidates cannot win in a
general election wow so when you put
them in driving everything to the
extremes there was i mean but my point
here is real quick
consider that now consider what the fbi
is doing
seems to make a bit more sense
they fund a bunch of these ultra maga
candidates then the fbi starts going
after trump and his inner circle to
taint the well and poison these
candidates so when they when they make a
criminal indictment of someone in the
trump circle or trump himself they can
say the criminal man himself endorsed
this candidate don't vote for him right
oh my god
oh
so ugly i mean there's also the
possibility that
um if they funded
maga candidates which is like smarter
than i am used to democrats being but
they they also would know if there's any
dirty linen because they have to do
opposition research right you know and
they save it for and they save it for
october for sure but
i think it could be even worse i think
that they there's an element of trying
to provoke
um republicans especially trump
supporters i think they're going to be
very shocking images we're going to see
you know with and god forbid i hope i'm
wrong and i have to be non-partisan so
i'm saying this very carefully but um i
think we're going to see images of like
the president in handcuffs or the
president in a perp walk or the
president
behind bars or some kind of highly
iconic image um and
and i think that the goal is to provoke
and we're gonna get and i'm seeing it
already a lot of like social media like
um whipping people's emotions up
instigators infiltrators and violence
and that's and that will be a
justification for a crackdown state of
emergency you can't vote in person you
have to vote by mail and then of course
we know the vulnerabilities with them
yeah trump trust me to count your votes
for you guys everyone give me a piece of
paper i'll tell you what the talent is
what uh yeah i mean that's that's the
argument uh i completely agree with ian
that we have a proprietary company we
have a company with proprietary software
code in how our voting voting is handled
they should be public i totally agree i
also think people should photograph
their vote and we've offered at daily
cloud you can send it to us and we'll
create a you know a locked third-party
kind of platform where you can mirror
your vote and at least there will be a
record of it what are your thoughts on
january 6th
a lot of them huh
i mean
it's a very difficult thing to answer
partly because speech about january 6th
is being criminalized
i think i will just say that you know
the rule of law is incredibly important
both
you know to protect
our institutions and also to protect the
rights of people who are accused of
crimes and the other thing i will say is
that very generally america has a long
history of infiltrators and provocateurs
yup i remember watching a video a long
time ago i was out of canada where it
was some leftist protest and there were
three guys that were wearing what was
very obviously a uniform like they were
undercover cops and they were like this
is what protesters wear put on a hoodie
jeans and boots and then everyone's like
those three guys dressed the exact same
and started throwing bottles right you
know so we hear a lot of stories like
that there was that story out of i think
it was minnesota where a guy shows up
and smashes out windows and then leaves
i don't know exactly what would happen
with that but i guess the concern now is
you know with ray epps i'm sure you're
familiar with the ray up saga here's a
guy on camera telling people to go in
the building and now the media is
calling him a victim
so you got uh there was a report
yesterday
that uh armed protesters were gonna show
up to mar-a-lago and everyone
immediately says feds because no no the
right doesn't protest they almost never
go outside and and what
well they go outside but not to protest
i mean for protests really yeah so so uh
but it's but it's obvious if you live in
a big city where it's predominantly
liberal it's really easy to walk outside
and see other people who agree with you
in march right if you live in a rural
area you could be
you know
between 100 yards and
and and uh and 10 miles from the nearest
person
not easy to organize that protest and
then where do you protest in cities it's
easy to walk from like town hall to like
the police station yeah but if you live
in a big unincorporated area what where
are you going to protest there's like
one to drive to d.c
what we end up seeing is
protests overwhelmingly tend to be left
or liberal
rarely are they right-wing or
conservative though they do happen
so when you get people showing up armed
and doing these writing protests people
just kind of roll their eyes like what
is going on you know yeah i mean to be
fair there were a lot of real people
really in of course dc to support the
president
right that's their right to show up in
dc to support the president i think uh
what was it like 200 000 some odd people
showed up to and then there was like 800
at the capitol
so they they demonize every single
person who was in dc to see trump speak
conflating
watching a man talk with storming into a
middle class that's the really scary and
and i must add they conflate the people
who stormed in the building with those
who were let in by on the other side of
the building it was a huge city block
that building and the people on one side
were breaking stuff the other people
were being led in by police and they've
threw them all in detention no no no let
those people out man it's time for a
great pardon i don't care any of them
joe biden dealings in ukraine he's
sending his son on the board of an
energy company in ukraine pardon him i
don't want i'm done under biden i'm done
with going after people right now
because if we try and persecute each
other it's just going to be passing the
football back and forth and back ian
it's not persecution it's justice i mean
our system calls for a trial by jury a
trial by one's peers people have to
be accountable for what they've done
we've supported the war machine for too
long we're all culpable
yeah but hunter biden
look i'll put it this way
the january 6 defendants who have been
locked up in like solitary that
shouldn't be happening i mean they can
be they can be under house arrest not
going anywhere did you see what uh
walkaway did at cpac they had like a
cage with someone listening to testimony
the whole time it was brilliant
you know so he was actually i think he
was actually convicted you know yeah is
it we've got those illnesses as
americans yes but look look you can you
can put hunter bite on trial we don't
got to throw in solitary you can put the
january 6 riders on trial you don't got
to put them in solitary i would i would
absolutely respect them being like look
you guys were violent okay
house arrest until your your court date
and then you get charged uh
based on with the crime you committed
that that's the reality of things hunter
biden yeah we want an investigation into
what he was doing in ukraine and in
china i want an investigation into what
joe biden's relationship was in all of
this sharing phone numbers sharing
emails
i don't think we just say
you know you you you're free to go we're
done but i'll put it this way
i do agree and i've said it before when
it comes to january 6 defendants a
powerful move would be to pardon all of
them as a sign of like we are seeking to
end but it's got to be nonpartisan i
wouldn't just pardon them you got to
pardon more than that
but i don't need to be rude but i i so
disagree with both of you about this
um
god where do i start i mean
so i'm a survivor of a very bad
crime when i was a child and um the
people who suffer most when the rule of
law is degraded are women and children
and what i'm seeing right now with
defund the police and this movement is
just crazy to defund the police or to
let people um you know commit a certain
amount of shoplifting before they get
arrested as in santa monica where i just
was or just the degradation of the rule
of law the rise of crime is that it
hurts women and children most
these i don't want to like get drawn
into details of january 6th but i will
say again that kantian imperative
we have to be against violence we have
to be against people breaking the law
whether it's there whether it's the you
know mercenaries who are beating
truckers in canada that's violence
that's against the rule of law whether
it's people being locked in solitary
confinement that's against the geneva
conventions that's against the rule of
law like everywhere we need to restore
and make consistent the rule of law but
rather than abandon it i believe but
isn't there just a i i understand ian's
point i don't know if i would go so far
as to be like hunter biden's free to go
i maybe i'm a little biased when i say
the january 6 rioters or protesters but
the idea there is if we keep doing a tit
for tat it's going to escalate and keep
escalating like right you said the right
thing tim you said like there is a a
code of
penalties for
certain laws it's very cut and dry i
mean the law is a beautiful thing if you
really look at it
you know each person
not just there but anywhere across the
country antifa everybody you know
if they committed a crime the crime will
be in that state
book of crimes and there's a penal code
and they should you know be tried and
sentenced fairly or tried and acquitted
fairly um it's the politicization that's
so dangerous
i want to pardon these people because
one it acknowledges that they did commit
a crime right now no one's acknowledging
that biden committed a crime that i can
see in like in the position of power
james clapper said we did not wittingly
spy on americans with the prison program
we did he did he and his department
willingly spied on me he he committed
perjury pardon him
acknowledge that he committed the crime
and pardoned him
because right now people are pretending
like he didn't commit a crime it's even
worse but why not um like investigate
him and try him because i don't want to
hurt these people i want to help the
species what you're describing seems
like a political prisoner swap to me
we're just going to keep trading back
and forth like oh well this is a
democrat who doesn't remember so here's
a republican occasionally the green
party is going to be like what do we do
to like get someone like at the end of
the day it doesn't seem as productive it
sounds nice but i think ultimately
you're right like we have rule of law
for a reason we should indict people and
investigate them and bring them to a
fair trial but just saying well like we
think maybe you did something hunter but
we can't prove it but preemptively we'll
pardon you so we can pardon these other
people so later we can pardon him like
it just seems complicated and
unproductive to me
geez i mean the last two years have been
horribly unproductive it's like the
united states is an abusive relationship
beating each other and there's a whole
world out there that we're not paying
attention to because they're too busy
beating each other and i'm tired of it
so i totally agree with you about that
so i suppose the issue the divisiveness
yes
you know we all sit here and i think
we've actually started paying attention
all of us at some point
and we learned some interesting facts
about what joe biden was doing
i see these memes on the left where
they're like donald trump committed 34
crimes or something like that and it's
like all made up like russia gate was
fake ukraine gate was fake and they just
make these stories up these people are
convinced they're seeking justice
not all of them some of them are just
tribal but a lot of them are like trump
committed crimes he has to be held
accountable and it's like what crimes
and they're like
documents thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you